more protests are expected in
Minneapolis over the decision not to
charge officers involved in a deadly
shooting Thurmond Blevins was killed by
two Minneapolis police officers on June
23rd they say he pointed a gun at them
during a short chase hundreds protested
in downtown Minneapolis yesterday
blocking intersections and rail lines
Dean Reynolds is in Minneapolis where he
spoke to Blevins family Dean good
morning good morning well this is the
alley where Thurman Blevins was shot as
he fled from two Minneapolis Police
officers we spoke to his family who
admitted that yes he did have a gun on
him at the time but they believe the
officers overreacted why did he run it
was the way that they approached him
when they came out of the vehicle
Thurman Blevins sister darlin and cousin
Sidney brown say he feared for his life
when he ran from police I mean who else
is not gonna run or somebody's behind me
telling me I'm like shoot you i'ma kill
you after a two-block chase officers
Justin Schmidt and Ryan Kelly opened
fire 14 times and killed Blevins moments
before they shot the police say body cam
video shows Blevins turn toward the
officers with a gun in hand ready to
fire something both officers say
happened before I pulled the trigger
when the gun came out I feared for my
life I feared for my partner's life I
remember seeing that barrel pointed
right at me and I'm pretty sure he got a
shot off and in about another quarter of
a second I have my gun out and now I'm
firing shots back at him what about the
notion that the police say he fired the
weapon that's not true we believe that
is false and we are calling for a better
party investigation in regards of that
the family believes it did not matter
how Blevins responded they say the
officers were intent on coming out
shooting if he had followed their
command he'd probably be alive don't you
think not necessarily not necessarily
they would have shot him even if he had
his hands up yes it happens all the time
it happens all the time with black man
that doesn't mean that Durr we're gonna
not shoot him the family told us they
want the case reopened and they intend
to pursue all legal avenues against the
two officers Nora all right Dean thank
you